un accord a été conclu entre Israël et
le Hamas pour une trêve de 4 jours et la
libération de 50 Otages est-ce que vous
avez la confirmation qu'il y aura des
otages français parmi eux écoutez soyons
très très prudent sur ce sur ce
sujet n'oublion pas la Genèse
l'agression d'une une organisation
terroriste qui tue
1400 civils israéliens et naturellement
un enchaînement d'un droit légitime d'un
pays à se défendre avec les conséquences
qu'on connaît toute reprise de
discussion qui permettent quelque part
de libérer des otages d'avoir un temps
pour permettre aux civils
d'évacuer les théâtres de guerre est un
élément positif et puis se poser la
question de quelle solution demain dans
cette partie du Proche Orient c'est un
sujet sur lequel je suis personnellement
assez engagé à un momentù plus personne
n'y croyait je pense à la suite des
accords d'Abraham je continue à prenner
une solution à deux états accord
d'Abraham entre Israël et certains pays
arabes et dans un dialogue naturellement
parce que il y a un droit d'Israël à
exister reconnu depuis 1948 et il y a un
droit aux citoyens israéliens d'exercer
librement leur citoyenneté solution à
deux états est-ce qu'il faut un cesser
le feu après cette trêve de 4 jours
écoutez chaque chose en son temps chaque
chose en son la réalité c'est qu'il
reste derrière 50 aotages il en restera
190 et que la réalité c'est tous les
otage qu'il faut libérer c'est tous les
otages j'allais dire sans distinction ni
de
nationalité ni
d'âge